we're back with another movie this time
the movie is children who chase lost
voices let's jump right into it a
charming and sharply intellectual girl
with a cheery demeanor wearing a school
bag wakes up from a slumber she seems to
be having on the train tracks and starts
running in the direction of a cliff it's
a cave she lifts the wooden door walks
inside the cave office with a desk and a
bookshelf and takes off her bag she
picks a box hidden in the books and runs
out of the cave to the head of the top
of the cliff she sits and pours some tea
out of her flask and takes out a box of
cookies wait the box doesn't contain
cookies it's a strange device or perhaps
a radio that's powered by a crystal the
girl takes a bite of her sandwich and
starts fiddling with the frequency to
catch signals she shares her excitement
of catching signals with a
squirrel-tailed cat mimi and indulges in
a mysterious melody
the girl walks into an apartment which
happens to be her home she prays folds
laundry cooks and looks after other
things around the house on her own it's
been a while since she heard the melody
and wonders if she's ever going to hear
it again
this young girl is asuna who's the best
student in class but is otherwise a
lonely character in this movie her
father died when she was a child and a
mother dedicated herself to a nursing
career that consumes almost all of her
waking hours arsenal spends most of her
time outside of school alone listening
for signals on a radio gadget connected
to a crystal her father gave her the
school teacher warns about a danger
nearby a bear's being detected prowling
the area and asks all students to be
careful and go home in pairs ironically
arsenal runs into that bear but it's not
a bear it's a giant creature with fangs
that are drooling as it sees its prey
just when this creature is about to
attack her she's rescued by a mysterious
teenager
[Music]
[Music]
the teenager apologizes for the scary
situation carries asuna hops onto the
train and then jumps from the bridge
this rescuer isn't your typical
adolescent folk the lad's name is shoon
asuna is unconscious the lad puts her
down on the ground and says i'm sure i
came here to meet you as arsenal wakes
up from asleep the boy tells her that
the danger is over and she can now go
back home safely she thanks him for
saving her life the boy walks away by
warning her to not come near the
mountain again and disappears all of a
sudden mimi's there and she follows the
boy too
after this incident arsenal misses
school meanwhile the police are
investigating the incident so the bridge
is closed the girl is determined to go
to the bridge again in the hope to see
that boy and so does the police end up
finding the monster in the river under
the bridge and see flowers and crystals
grown on its body
asuna decides to go to the forest and
find the boy apparently the lad was
hoping she would come the two introduced
themselves arsenal quickly notices his
wound and rushes to the cave to grab
first aid she's created her own space
there and collected all kinds of stuff
hoping one day that she might use them
she treats his wound and shows him the
best spot to listen to the radio the two
listen to music and have sandwiches shun
explains to asuna that he's from the
kingdom of agartha and he's come to this
place in search of something perhaps
he's found it he then kisses asuna on
the forehead and gives her a benediction
asuna rushes away telling soon she'll be
back tomorrow shun now alone talks to
mimi and asks it to take care of her he
also confesses the song she heard on the
radio was his he gazes up at the stars
before collapsing to his death from the
cliff
asuna's mother is back home it's sunday
and astronaut tells her mother she has
to see a friend and will be back home at
six she spends the day in the cave
hoping to see shun again who's nowhere
to be found the next morning arsenal's
mom tells her the police found the dead
body of a boy in the river shocked by
the news she refuses to accept it shun
mr morisaki the substitute teacher is
giving a lecture on a book when he
mentions agatha the land of the dead
which catches asuna's attention she goes
to the teacher after school and asks him
about agartha the teacher explains that
long ago when humanity was young it
needed the supervision of ancient gods
the same monster that shun saved her
from until the humanity grew up and the
existence of the gods was no longer
necessary they hide themselves as
gatekeepers of the underworld it's said
to be a place where any kind of wish can
be fulfilled even resurrecting the dead
arsenal leaves her teacher's place and
returns home considering what they've
discussed but she's interrupted when her
cat mimi chases after a glittering
object at her hangout leading her to
shin a boy who looks precisely like shun
and holds the same crystal as shun did
but has a colder disposition
while talking the archangels a group of
men emerge at that very moment and
attack both they're hoping to find a
garther on their own when the cave's
entrance is bombarded the strange boy
hides with arsuna in the underground
entrance and the two go deeper into the
cave
inside the cave they come across a
gatekeeper who appears to have lost his
bodily senses and attacks the youngster
he refuses to murder the gatekeeper and
instead gives arsenal his clavis a
crystal and runs back to fight the
monster when he thought he'd won the
fight the monster attacks him and
injures asuna rushes and tries to
protect him at the very last moment the
archangels intervene and they end up
killing the gatekeeper the archangel
commander catches asuna and opens a
portal to agartha with the clavis the
commander and asuna are the first to
enter the portal followed by the boy
once they reach inside the mysterious
commander exposes he's none other than
mr morisaki the substitute teacher the
young lad is shin shoon's little brother
hence the resemblance the teacher tells
the boy that he wishes to bring his wife
back to life shin tells asuna that shun
is dead and that she doesn't need a
clevis to open the exit portal then the
boy submerges into the ocean mr morisaki
explains that he's part of the archangel
and has been researching the land of
agartha for 10 years the organization
doesn't have good intentions though the
teacher offers asuna the option of
returning home but she chooses to tag
along they both enter the realm through
an underwater portal once they reach
inside the duo and mimi who had smuggled
herself into asuna's backpack traveled
to the gate of life and death which may
bring the souls of the dead back to life
when shin returns to his village he's
informed that he failed his mission to
retrieve the clavis because asuna had
with her the crystal from the radio and
that she could open the gates any time
shin must now go back and stop her and
the teacher from unleashing chaos along
the way arsenal is kidnapped by strange
monsters suddenly she wakes up in a
confined space and finds another little
girl who happens to be kidnapped as well
the two get along quickly and decide to
run away as the day grows darker the
monsters emerge but they can only move
in the shadows the two girls meet shin
during their escape attempt who try to
help them but is wounded by the monsters
morisaki becomes successful in finding
them with mimi's help shin tries to grab
clavic's crystal fragment from the
teacher however he's too weak to fight
back and morisaki quickly overcomes him
later they're headed to the little girls
village when they arrive the natives are
initially hesitant to assist the top
dwellers but the village leader
persuades the guards to let them in
because they've brought the little girl
back the elder lets them stay one night
in the hamlet but they're not allowed to
stay longer due to agatha's history of
top dwellers bringing bad luck in the
meantime arsenal goes to check on shin
but he yells at her to leave him alone
asuna and her teacher leave the village
by boat the next morning but mimi no
longer wants to accompany them shin
wakes up and finds that mimi has died
shin the little girl and the elder then
proceed to deliver mimi's body to the
ancient god
shin resolves to go after the villagers
to protect asuna when he sees them
riding away to kill her and the teacher
monisaki and asuna are walking towards a
steep precipice when the villagers
attack them but shin comes to their
rescue the teacher tells that the gate
of life and dead is at the bottom of the
cliff arsenal tries to descend but is
too terrified while the teacher carries
on after exchanging his gun for her
clavichard and instructs her to return
to the surface shin is fighting the
villagers and is ready to die when the
villagers realize the clevis crystal has
arrived at the gate of life and death
they abandon shin since he's betrayed
them while the sun's going down the
shadow creatures chase after asuna
following her teacher's orders she stays
in the water at night she's attacked by
the creatures when the water runs out
but shin saves her again after viewing
the arc of life descend the two return
to the ledge they come across an ancient
god on the verge of death the god
performs his song before he dies in
order to send all of his memories into
the world upon hearing the song arsenal
realizes that the last song she heard in
her world was shun song before he died
the god offers to lead them to the
cliff's bottom they both find the gate
of life and death at the foot of the
cliff and enter it monosaki has already
made a wish for his late wife lisa to
return but it's not that easy she will
need a vessel the teacher warns asuna
that she shouldn't come and she's soon
possessed by the soul of morisaki's wife
but this isn't enough he must also pay
for it and ends up losing one of his
eyes shin manages to destroy the crystal
to remove arsenal's possessions even
though the teacher had held a knife to
his throat after a brief reunion with
mimi and shun breaking the clevis
returns arsenal's spirit to her body
lisa encourages her husband to find
happiness without her before she leaves
the girl's body
arsenal has now returned to her old self
but the teacher is heartbroken requests
shin to kill him the boy reminds the
teacher that carrying the burden of a
deceased loved one is humanity's curse
and encourages him to continue living
arsenat returns to the surface she's
shown saying her goodbyes to shin and
morisaki who've decided to stay in
agatha in the closing scene asuna
returns to japan and graduates from
elementary school but she never forgets
the memories and the lessons that shin
and her teacher taught her hope you
enjoyed this movie see you in the next
video don't forget to subscribe to never
miss out on new and amazing anime recaps